in honor of Thanksgiving in the new
movie Penguins of Madagascar I'm doling
out hearty helpings of commentary about
CG animated spin-offs check it out on
this week's episode up angry nerd Oh
tastes like chicken I am surprised at
how thankful I am for the Penguins of
Madagascar okay boys this is it the
mission you've been preparing for our
entire lives
I think this crack squad of flightless
waterfowl is the one delicious
ingredient in the otherwise unappetizing
Madagascar franchise a franchise that I
will always associate with this lazy bit
of slapstick from their first film an
elderly woman can do kung fu' get it and
to kick to the groin - whoa
comedy gold watch your backs empowered
but I'll be there on opening day for the
penguin spin-off movie even though I
have zero interest in Madagascar 4 do in
2018 you know I feel exactly the same
way about the Shrek franchise first
movie good a second movie I'm gonna just
stop talking finally third movie
excruciating MooMoo and oh gee I forgot
there was a fourth match are you okay
if you think the fourth one was
defensible let me know in the comments
but I thought the Shrek spin-off
puss-in-boots was a booth you know warm
to make the can't angry it reminded me
of why I like to satirical fairytale
sensibility of the original Shrek in the
first place why was that spinoff so much
more fun than all of these sequels I
think that in the realm of the
blockbuster CG animated feature where
high concept is king sequels are always
Terran eyes by the template of the
original film it's like the creators go
into the sequel knowing that they have
to toil and sweat to come up with some
new twist on the original film's premise
it feels fresh bow-bow it doesn't stray
too far from the established paradigm
and you can totally tell that it feels
like work to them
I think Despicable Me 2 had this problem
and I was underwhelmed by it
the only really enjoyable parts were the
ones with the minions
Ramsbottom and hey presto now there's
going to be a spin-off movie about the
minions
and once again I am so much more excited
about that than about Despicable Me 3
see these be story lines with supporting
characters like the minions and like the
Penguins and Puss in Boots they can feel
like a blessing relief from
uninteresting plot machination x' you
get the sense that the filmmakers were
playing hooky and actually having fun
with these sequences spin-off movies
with these side characters have the
potential to sidestep the sequel
syndrome so my message to the makers of
every animated feature that is currently
in pre-production you know that that
secondary comic relief character that's
really starting to pop throw your
central premise in the garbage and build
a movie around that character also
they're working on a fifth Ice Age movie
I don't want to see that I think I speak
for everyone in the film going public
when I say blue sky you are not allowed
to release another entry in this
franchise until you give us an entire
feature about scratch who's with me
what side character from an animated
classic would you like to see get their
own film let me know in the comments
Thanksgiving is the most magical time of
year I love when all of the family
gathers together for marathon viewing
sessions on basic cable last year it was
the James Bond and the Star Trek
marathons on Sci Fi you know a lot of my
family hit a wall and they gave out
early you know take it from me you have
to train for a marathon all year long
what TV will you be watching during the
holiday let me know in the comments and
subscribe to the wired Channel